Mary here with a gamespot news update  the galloran or should we say the baller  horn is now being sold by sir depending  on your familiarity with destiny that's  either incredible news or you have no  idea what I'm talking about but it is  incredible news galler horn is the most  powerful rocket launcher in the game and  many strategies for high-level raids  relied on it it was sold once before in  the second week the game was released  but its power wasn't yet widely realized  ever since then the only way to get a  gala horn was from a random drop making  it extremely rare and highly coveted sir  appeared on schedule this morning and  will be in the tower until Saturday  night the subreddit for the game is  declaring a holiday and it's now  decorated by galler horns with the  launch of the next dlc the taken King in  September several new guns will be added  to the game so the gallery warns rain  could soon be over for everything else  destiny related be sure to head to  gamespot com